[Musique]
bonjour je suis Athis Barret conseil
municipal à la ville de Poissy
aujourd'hui nous sommes au parc
maisonniers je suis avec Fanny ainsi que
Mariela pour vous expliquer un petit peu
son rituel de rentrée par rapport à
Fanny Mariella est-ce que vous pouvez
nous en dire un petit peu par rapport à
la rentrée de Fanny ce qui est un petit
rituel bien sûr alors elle commence
d'abord par prendre un petit bain nous
le faisons nous-mêmes sur la terrasse
nous la peignons et la des produits pour
nettoyer les oreilles c'est le
vétérinaire qui s'occupe de couper ses
ongles parce que j'ai un petit peu peur
et
cette année on a opté pour faire des
petits plats maison
composé de blanc de poulet de riz et des
haricots verts ce sont des choses que
les chiens peuvent manger une rentrée au
petit soin et voilà c'est ça
voici sa trousse en fait elle est rose
comme elle est coquettes bien évidemment
bah son shampoing
ça c'est le produit pour nettoyer les
oreilles
on nous avons une brosse
là il y a les poils qui sort
donc d'abord son shampoing ensuite on la
brosse voilà c'est ça et puis ensuite on
sèche bien et puis les oreilles et bon
bah là il fait chaud mais quand il fait
froid elle a le droit de la base line
sur les coussinets
[Musique]
voilà vous aussi prenez soin de vos
animaux surtout en cette période où les
animaux sont énormément abandonnés avant
d'aller récupérer un animal pensez à
partir à la SPA vous avez beaucoup
d'animaux qui attendent de l'amour comme
Mariella on donne pour Fanny
[Musique]